she was like listen I think it's just
cut this off now like you great we're
not what I'm looking for I'm really
sorry so I ended up going to the game
with a friend later that night I looked
up at the kiss-cam and there she was
some other guy at the game happy
Valentine's Day I'm Michaela and I'm
gonna go around and ask my co-workers
what's your most depressing story about
love I'm also gonna make them wear this
duct ad so they realize how stupid they
are for falling in love in the first
place after hearing all they're
depressing at stories you'll be happy
you're single I don't yeah
very upsetting i exac in trouble yeah
high school we used to do this thing
where you could buy roses for people and
they would get delivered in class and
you'd be like super popular if you got
some and no one ever sent me an roses so
I made up names and sent some to myself
don't off me Ashley
whatever I can look cool for the day and
self-love is the best kind of love him
all right my most depressing story about
love is that I spent most of my life
like pining after random dudes who
didn't care and then ended up dating my
friends but one day you'll find love
it'll be fine I was at an amusement park
with my friends and I was with this one
of my guy friends he does this and what
I'm thinking he's doing is going like
well come on turns out what he was doing
was putting his hands just in his in his
pocket when he realized what I was doing
he was like oh and instead of taking
that as a physical like hint to stop
what I'm doing I just forced my arm in
between his arm and his torso until
finally I was like oh so I went to his
phone and I was like searching for a
name right and I couldn't find anything
so I was like let's get creative so I
searched for the word babe and I put
search and I found all the different
times we had called somebody else babe
oh I found that he was talking to this
other guy I decided I was okay maybe we
can like get past this and when I
decided to lay next to him the bed broke
in half down the middle
IKEA beds you know
and then we just decided to break up and
that was that disclaimer is mad Petty
and I was mad young I put that in there
I was mad young I yo she's still coming
home late I'm like take a shower before
you go to bed I'm big on that but she
ain't do it and she used to work in the
restaurant and then one day I woke up
there's a piece of chicken on my bed now
we broke up Hey
and honestly I was offended because just
let me hold your arm you pull we're
friends
whatever I haven't talked to him since I
hope he sees it and I hope he hates
worried that I'm just kidding I'll be
back here with
I don't I don't I don't want everyone to
be happy